lock him to this video playing a rook
from the US suelo retina isn't here
usually higher is also doing touch in
yugioh bride I was higher but not not a
lot mostly a bullet player I believe
yeah join my queen bee three line again
a six yeah b5 is quite quite ambitious
let's say let's call it ambitious but
weakens the queenside very much and I
really don't see why you would play a
six if you don't want to play b5 now ok
so just you three and continue to
develop ok this this kind of thing you
can always do with black setting up in
style of the Queens gambit declined ah
should I I wonder ever should take here
on somehow reacted to this idea of
capturing rookie one is also possible
yeah this is the setup for black just
make some sense it's not terribly bad or
anything he just chose a very
unconventional move order for it on the
B point I can place you five but still
he s got be six or be five
yeah maybe a book d 1 this is often a
good idea to make it for more difficult
for black to get in it the sea 535
breaks night h5 um okay we should be
five is the normal reaction to that
because 95 d 5 is not in black
self-interest oh it's doing that anyway
okay yeah the problem is a move like you
for not not now but but later and this
this opens the position to my to my
advantage yeah maybe even even if or
here but care what i want to get castle
at first and to know if form i can
always do that also next myth before you
know it can take on c4
yeah still prostate problem advantageous
for white but you can also take first
then play that it just opens up the
position oh he's giving up a pawn why
didn't he take Miss wells was this so
bad now I mean I died I take the pawn
and don't mind to take it okay rook to
d1 there's night f4 here and yeah i want
you i want to avoid that i have to ship
c4 in this position putting the pressure
on the f7 square and on the night let's
do that i'm behind on the clock and I
don't want to check get into a huge time
scramble against it I think he's a very
quick player being a good at bullet so
this looks very nice though I can't even
play you 6 young and that probably
should if you move the f porn this is 6
a-6 bond is really a nuisance I can't
check take it okay still in the big pin
so i don't want to simply take them how
to to increase the pressure rookie one
rookie six probably now one minute 46 we
are not sure what rookie sex is actually
doing maybe book c6 yeah Roxy six is a
threat okay yeah I wonder 95 or
something or cam let's get the King out
of the checks first so as always the
problem Quincy one check okay i can i
can take 860 cannot buy do that okay
it's got this this counter player with
93 but at the moment i'm still covering
this can check give the check first
maybe g for him time morning 23 I can
take but if you takes Bishop takes I'm
covering see 290 father's g5 check need
to need to trick
okay this is some technical plane check
I need to be somewhat precise here but
it should be should be doable even in
the time 95 is though and the key thing
check yo okay check check check check
black resigns yeah this wasn't a good
position out in the open a fine very
funny move order I wonder if I can
somehow exploit this there's a six yeah
probably not him maybe I should take
here actually and this is this precise
moment where you cannot take with the
Pont family that's possible this is not
bad for like it's a bit passive but it's
not bad until I was expecting be five or
taking on c4 and then be five okay maybe
if it takes i have also had the idea to
take with the Queen so that c6 is
actually attacked Saudi tech see Queen
takes b5 Queen c6 this this is also ok
but I don't think that taking is so
great here I don't like it for black g
for the threat and that will probably
open up the center to my advantage like
it happened but here I didn't get why he
was giving away the pawn black can take
and play blu should be six I mean this a
thought should be nice for me
I mean not brilliant but but okay I have
ideas like this but black shouldn't be
in in any substantial danger here yet
yeah I'm just taking the corn with the
big big advantage check this is just
just a very nice position check this was
so I think a reasonably convincing just
take everything check I hear Bishop g8r
bishop g8 is a nice smooth they I didn't
see that push should be g8 very nice
this oh he had he had a strong move here
Queenie too interesting most very
interesting if I take Roxy to very tough
to find this cute so what's best bishop
g8 again mmm funny rook takes and now
take on f5 hmm funny Luke g7 is supposed
to be the best here and yeah very
computer is line he he didn't see that
and I gave away the BCM okay be an
interesting game again thanks for
watching